Dr. Zakir, as many of the shows we've
started off with definition of the terms
and this episode will be none different
in the sense that I'd like you to first
and foremost
to define the term what exactly does
Isla mean
especially in the context of Ramadan.
The Arabic word Isla means to correct.
It means to improve.
It means to repair.
Whenever one Muslim corrects another
Muslim
or he improves him, it is called as
Isla.
For example, if a Muslim is making a
mistake
whether in offering salah or in any of
the acts of Islam or anything.
If someone corrects him it's called as
Isla.
And it's mentioned in the Quran.
Surah Hud, chapter number 11, verse
number 88.
My only desire
is your improvement.
Is your betterment to the best of my
power.
And
my success will only come from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And I trust in him
and I look up to him.
I trust in Allah and I look up to Allah.
So here we realize that Shu'aib alayhis
salaam, he wanted to Isla to his people.
It's further mentioned in the Quran in
Surah Nisa, chapter number four, verse
number 114.
It says that in their secret talks there
is no good
except
for a person who desires a good deed
of charity
or justice
or reconciliation
between two Muslims.
If such a deed he does
then secrecy is permissible.
And if someone does such a deed
seeking the pleasure of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala, he'll get the reward which is
very high. Otherwise, normally secret
talks
most of the time it's not good except
for
deeds of charity
of justice and reconciliation between
two Muslims.
So here we realize that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala, he says that one Muslim
should try and improve the other Muslim.
He should do Isla with him.
He should correct him.
And Allah says in the Quran in Surah Al
Imran, chapter number three, verse
number 110.
We Muslims, we are the best of people
evolved for mankind. Allah is giving us
an honor and calling us Muslims as the
Khaira Ummah, the best of people evolved
for mankind.
And Allah continues.
He's calling us the best of people
because we are supposed to enjoin what
is good and forbid what is wrong and
believe in Allah.
If we do not enjoin what is good and if
we do not forbid what is wrong, we are
unfit to be called as Khaira Ummah. We
are unfit to be called as Muslims. So
it's the duty of every Muslim that he
should do Isla
and Dawah
and try and improve
his fellow Muslim.
And there's a Hadith of our beloved
Prophet Muhammad alayhis salaam.
It's mentioned in Sahih Muslim, volume
number one
in the book of
faith
Hadith number 79
where the beloved Prophet Muhammad
alayhis salaam said that if any of the
Muslims
see anything which is abominable,
anything which is wrong
he should stop it with his hand.
If he does not have the strength to do
that
he should stop it with his tongue.
If he does not have the strength to do
that, then he should at least abhor it
in his heart. He should at least curse
in his heart. And then he will have the
least degree of faith.
That means if you abhor it in your
heart, if you curse in your heart, you
are the lowest level of moment.
That's the reason Isla is a very
important part of the Muslim's life.